MARCO CASALAINA: All right.
Hello, everybody.
Thank you for joining us.
I'm Marco Casalaina.
I'm VP Products of CoreAI.
AYCA BAS: Hi, everyone.
I'm Ayca, and I'm a Developer
Advocate at Microsoft.
MARCO CASALAINA: All right.
We're going to talk
about the four IQs.
There were three, and
now there are four.
So, Ayca, what is the deal?
What are the four IQs?
AYCA BAS: Yes.
So seems like IQs are pretty
hot topic this Build.
MARCO CASALAINA: Yeah.
AYCA BAS: And, as you know,
when we build demo agents,
we can actually use and build
any data source we want.
But, in the real-world, our
data is across the board.
So we need files.
We need structured data,
unstructured data,
human context.
So IQs are actually bringing the
old context data and also M365
into our agent, which
is pretty cool.
MARCO CASALAINA: Yeah.
That's right.
So there are four IQs.
We got Web IQ, Foundry IQ,
Fabric IQ, and Work IQ.
What do each one of these
things actually do?
AYCA BAS: Right.
Okay. Let me get
started with Web IQ.
So Web IQ wires your agent
into all that web knowledge
that actually is pretty useful
because, if you have, let's say,
if you need local information
like the demo you did yesterday,
if you need to check,
let's say, shipment delays
or all those information,
you kind of need
that service in place.
MARCO CASALAINA: Yeah.
AYCA BAS: So Work IQ is
where we connect M365
data in your agent.
That means you can
actually check your emails
or Teams messages, all sorts of
data available in Microsoft 365.
And then Fabric IQ, do you
want to cover Fabric IQ?
MARCO CASALAINA: All right.
So Fabric IQ is for
structured data,
largely for structured data.
And you think about you
as humans, you might get
to this data with a Power BI
report or something like that.
But that doesn't work for an
agent, so you need some kind
of an agentic face,
a headless way
for these agents to
get to your data.
So Fabric IQ is all about
providing this kind
of headless access
and maintaining the context
that's necessary for your agent
to hit that structured
data in Work IQ.
AYCA BAS: Foundry IQ.
MARCO CASALAINA: Oh.
And Foundry IQ is largely
for unstructured data.
So these are your blob stores
and your search indices,
SharePoint and all
that kind of stuff.
Foundry IQ is an agentic
retrieval mechanism
that allows your
agents to do that kind
of agentic retrieval rather
than simple old-fashioned
rag that's existed
for like three years.
That makes it old-fashioned
in this market.
Now, Ayca and I pair-programmed
a lot of this stuff.
So we've been working
together for a while,
working towards Build
and stuff like that.
Let's talk a little bit about
so now with the IQs we did,
and now we got this
on the screen here.
I think you could
see it somewhere;
or you could put the
PC on the screen.
AYCA BAS: I think they can.
MARCO CASALAINA: Production
folks, I hope you can see that.
Now, we've only got
four tools in here.
We got the four IQs.
And, yet, there are still
some idiosyncrasies
about making your agent call the
right tool at the right time.
How did you -- how
did you do that?
How did we do that?
AYCA BAS: Exactly.
I think we should also explain
that these services
are very new.
So all those tools
are coming together,
and Product Teams are working
so hard to bring them together.
So we are in very early
stages of IQs right now.
So, to be able to make them
work in a pretty good shape,
let's say production ready
shape, then you kind of need
to maybe work on
your instructions,
agent instructions.
So we went through
a lot of iterations
of this agent instructions,
and maybe Marco can cover
that a little bit too.
But what we have here is very
good and identified descriptions
for every IQ and how we need
to work together with them,
all of the mapping for,
let's say, Fabric IQ.
And, if I scroll down a little
more, you will see that,
if you're using Work IQ,
there are critical things
when you're doing search;
when you are doing do action,
which means if you're doing
any, let's say, sending emails,
etc. We are putting all those
rules so that our agent
that can actually consume
the IQ content in a shape
that we want them to be.
So we also even have examples of
some JSON buddy that means that,
when Work IQ is
receiving our query,
it is pretty much converting our
content into a shape we want to
and all those stuff
plus everything
about Web IQ available
in our instructions.
So it actually plays
a really big role.
Having said that, if you just
plug them into an agent and try
to test, it will
probably work; but,
if you want a really good
performance out of the IQs,
you should definitely consider
adjusting the instructions.
MARCO CASALAINA: Right.
So the moral of story is
the purpose of these IQs
or really one of
the main purposes
of these IQs is
preventing context rot.
It's removing so you don't have
to put all of this context stuff
in each individual agent that
you build, all the context
about your data and about your
unstructured data source,
about Microsoft ecosystem stuff.
But that does not absolve
you from still having
to put some context in here
to tell it what tool to call
when and what they do.
That is still on you or on
whatever coding agent you happen
to be using because, yes;
we absolutely did do
this with Copilot CLI.
Now, I think, to finish this
off, what is really interesting
about this, so here she
has the Foundry agent.
That's what it looks like
in the Foundry web portal.
But that is not how
we expose this agent.
How we exposed this agent is
fascinating and, honestly,
was a little bit
undersold here at Build
in the keynote and
stuff like that.
So, if you would, production
folks, if you can hear me,
please change to the Mac.
I'm on a Mac; she's on a PC.
So here we go.
So check this out.
So we did indeed expose
that same agent,
but what did we do with it?
We did this thing.
Out of that agent, we
made an agent template.
So this is an agent
template in A 365.
And what does that give you?
When you have an agent
template, what it does is this:
It allows you, or
really anybody,
to create an instance of this.
When you create an
instance of this agent,
you're not just
creating an agent.
So, when I created an
instance of this thing,
I didn't just make an agent.
I made my agent.
This is my instance of
this particular refund
processor agent.
That means you see it in the org
chart, and it reports to me.
That also means that it has
its own Teams box over here
and that it has its own inbox.
It has its own email address
and all that kind of stuff.
And so earlier I told it, check
your email for complaints,
and I mean your email.
To the agent, I'm like,
Check your email,
not my email, your email.
It has its own.
And it's able to
check its own email.
And, in fact, it sent me back,
if I look at my own inbox
in here, you can see that
it sent to Maria Garcia,
it sent a reply;
and it copied me.
Now, this is hugely
advantageous.
Not all agents are
going to be like this.
But there are certain class
of agents that you want
to have their own
identity like this,
and there is specifically
for security.
For one thing, if we think
about, say I go over here
to ClawPilot, which keeps
signing me out today.
So here I am in ClawPilot.
Now, for those of you who
haven't seen this before,
this is our kind of
internal claw thing,
and it uses the heck
out of Work IQ.
Here earlier today I was making
it read a document for me,
and it used these tools.
It used Work IQ.
It used this to draft an
email and all this stuff.
But it was doing this
on behalf of me,
so that means this agent could
do anything that I can do.
However, that's not
always wonderful.
Wow. What is my mouse doing?
That is not always what
you want to be doing here.
So, in this case,
this agent runs
in its own security context.
It has its own permissions.
It can't just do
everything that I can do.
So I might say,
all right, agent.
You have the ability to send
emails, to send Teams messages
and stuff; but you
are not allowed
to delete stuff out of OneDrive.
I can; agent cannot.
So it has its own
security posture.
And so, as you start to think
about deploying these agents
to an organization,
you do need to think
about what is your
security posture.
And the on behalf of
security posture,
like what I was showing earlier,
is not always what you want.
What you do want, in many cases,
is an agent that has its own
identity, its own security.
AYCA BAS: Awesome, And if
you switch to my PC --
MARCO CASALAINA: Back to the PC.
AYCA BAS: -- I want to show,
and before we close this
out I want to show that, while
Marco was going through all
that chat with A 365 agent,
you can also see all
that in the traces of it
called between the tools,
between Work IQ and
then Fabric IQ;
and then Foundry IQ
returned saying that, Hey.
Maria Garcia, I
found her package.
And then I checked the policies,
and then I can actually
issue her a refund.
So I can email to Maria.
So all that is happening in sync
behind the scene calling all the
IQs in synchronously.
So this is pretty much what
we wanted to talk about.
But there is one thing
I want to mention.
MARCO CASALAINA: All right.
Of course, this is
just 13 minutes talk.
But, if you want to
learn more about IQs,
we have a series for you.
Just go ahead and check
out the IQ series.
It's ak.ms/iq-series.
We have episodes for you
about Foundry IQ, Work IQ;
and Fabric IQ and Web
IQ are coming soon.
And we also issue you a digital
badge if you complete cookbooks
and if you watch
all the episodes.
So you can show the
world that you're one
of the first experts about IQs.
Yeah. So that's pretty much it.
You want to close it out.
I will.
Thank you, Ayca.
And thank you all, and
use yourself some IQs.
Have a good day.
[ MUSIC ]